yeah sorry this reviews up a little
later than usual I just had to take 15
showers after watching the first 15
minutes of this movie holy God Oh golly
so the which is the feature film
directorial debut of writer and director
Robert Eggers needed to remember his
name because I'm horrible with names but
this dude really does have a career
ahead of him
so watch out for that name and it
concentrates on a family in the middle
of B Fe the middle of nowhere in New
England I believe this is the 1600s it
could be wrong about that and they're in
their cabin they're hanging out doing
whatever they do for entertainment is
1600 so you know the settlers from those
commercials it's like that but much more
gray so seriously the color palette in
the color scheme in this movie I was
like it's very cloudy and wet all the
time and I live in Washington State and
it bothered me however in the woods next
to these people there's a witch and so
horrific [ __ ] starts happening to this
family in a very subtle subtle way the
bummer about this movie is it's going to
start off on the wrong foot for a lot of
people because it is horribly miss
marketed there is one thing in the
trailer that can kind of get your mind
in the mindset for what this movie
actually is and that is when the trailer
talks about it got a lot of buzz at
Sundance it's an indie movie a Sundance
movie that got a lot of buzz right there
you should know it's a pretty artsy
movie I say that because I was in an
auditorium full of a bunch of stoner
teenagers they were like all right let's
get scary it wasn't really like that
Nell walked out like what the [ __ ] this
movie is a period piece that happens to
have some witchcraft elements that
starts subtly happening to this family
the closest thing I've seen this movie
be compared to and I was like that's
actually accurate was The Shining The
Shining set in the 1600s with a drab
really weathered looking family who all
talk like they're speaking out of the
King James Bible all the time say that
about the movie - the acting was awesome
because these people had to talk like I
love thee as doubt loves dine nay for
hither and sometimes when people speak
like that in movies you can tell they're
kind of scripting it out they're like I
not really feeling the dialogue everyone
in this movie I Bought that's how they
talked and the way they actually convey
it to the audience is like it's
remarkably natural good job actors
however you have to know this this movie
goes for the slow burn
sure and I'm gonna decode it for you
right here slow burn is artsy fartsy
film speak for a movie that was boring
in quite a few scenes now that's not to
say the movies bad I'm not saying the
movies bad the movie certainly has
quality I'm just saying that's true
assimilate the information however you
want I'm just saying if I looked into my
camera and said yes movie never bored me
at all whatsoever I've been lying my ass
off and I don't want to do that but it
has tone for days that's what the movie
is is tone in tension because it's
tension for the sake of tension not
tension for the sake of payoff what I
mean by that is just tension winding and
winding and even in the end of the movie
it's just like alright we wound the
tension you don't really have a release
there's some disturbing imagery in a few
parts in the movie but all in all it is
tension for the sake of tensions like ha
attention because tension one of the
things I really liked about this movie
is one of the things you'll see if you
see it and I feel like a lot of people
will see it but it's camouflaged under a
really disturbing and creepy vibe but
you notice that there are a lot of
elements taken from fairytales that you
know what better way to get adults to be
scared to the dark again and take their
childhood memories of fairytales that
are all nice and lobbied all happy and
just kind of burn it to the ground I'll
say this and I gotta lay it down on the
level which is a period piece about a
family and that's what you got to know
going into it if you go for great acting
in a period piece about a family living
in the middle of nowhere with creepy
atmosphere you'll enjoy the movie but if
you're going to this movie for a scary
movie you're gonna be disappointed and I
think that's just a fact of life in the
end I enjoyed the witch but I didn't
enjoy the movie as much as every other
reviewer and every other critic out
there did that I've seen anyway a lot of
people like oh the witch give me the
wedge and I'm like yeah I mean I enjoyed
it I feel like my response in this
videos gonna be underwhelming for the
people who are blowing up my Twitter
like oh my god you got to talk about the
witch I'm somewhere in the middle with
this movie and I will say the witch is a
good time no alcohol required
let's hope people actually came here for
my opinion this is the movie people are
talking about this weekend so the witch
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more